and white's king's just going to march  in and um  over-excited though yeah maybe  maybe i'm telling this all wrong  maybe it's so difficult  these positions are lost yes  that's what i was talking about  that's what i was taught at least okay  maybe we're doing something new  no but i i don't think oh and now he's  blunted a rook ah  okay let's go back to the place cameras  because the game ends abruptly  um okay mishra unable to defend there  and gives up oh after a long fighter of  emanuel misra  eventually loses this game um maybe he  wasn't down to that  blunder magnus but being 12 years old  you'd run out of energy maybe  or just fighting spirit in the end here